republicans are increasingly endorsing a
conspiracy theory according to the
left-wing rag slate.com
and it is apparently
all my fault
i your humble host am now officially a
conspiracy theorist according to
slate.com get me a tinfoil hat bring me
my gay frogs i have apparently led
republicans astray
by persuading them to sign on to my
public health protection pledge
which slate alleges makes a boogeyman
out of dr anthony fauci and links him
quote to an ominous history with covid19
that is the headline
to date wright slate
more than a dozen congressional
candidates have signed this pledge which
was authored by the daily wires michael
knowles
this is true
sitting members of congress have
endorsed my pledge too by the way so
it's not just the candidates it's
actually members of congress congressman
paul gosar introduced it as an official
house resolution just this month so that
part's totally right what's the
conspiracy theory that i'm peddling you
might ask what is the accusation that i
have made well slate slate continues
they say
to be clear the pledge itself makes no
specific accusations
of wrongdoing
huh it's kind of weird slate accused us
of peddling a conspiracy theory but then
immediately admitted that we did no such
thing we didn't peddle any theory at all
slate then focuses the rest of the
article on what it calls the gain of
function
conspiracy theory that is it describes
quote an idea that incorrectly connects
u.s funding that was used by the wuhan
institute of virology to study bat
coronaviruses to a theory also incorrect
that the institute created and leaked
covid19
now the strange thing about the
incorrect conspiracy theory that that
slade is talking about
is that it is a pretty well established
fact which even slate admits just a few
paragraphs later conceding that quote
fauci funded an experiment at the wuhan
institute of virology in which a
modified coronavirus proved unexpectedly
infectious at which point quote the nih
pulled funding for the project
slate goes on to admit that the
experiment that was indirectly funded
could actually have been classified as
gain of function according to several
experts and that
there is legitimate scientific debate
over the merits of conducting such
experiments on viruses because of their
potential to spread disease or start
pandemics
did the virus come from the lab
many leading public health officials and
experts say yes it very very possibly
very likely even did in other words
after defaming me
and dozens of republicans as conspiracy
theorists
slate admits that we aren't endorsing
any particular theory at all and the
theory we might have endorsed is true
we could much more plausibly accuse
slate and the rest of the left-wing
media by the way of being conspiracy
theorists but that wouldn't be quite
fair because they know better than the
nonsense and the bile that they are
spewing they admit it after the headline
they know that we are raising the right
questions and telling the truth
that is why they're lying and libeling
us and that is exactly why we've got to
keep pushing because these crooks and
liars are showing us that we are right
over the target i'm glad you like that
clip
if you want to get more clips ring the
bell subscribe get notifications one way
to really guarantee you get
notifications in case our friends here
at big tech
don't send them to you for whatever
reason is to head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe to the michael knowles show
leave a five star review we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you